[Music]
what is the polynomial function it is a
function of the form f of X is equal to
n multiplied by X raise to n plus a and
minus 1 multiplied by X raise to n minus
1 and so on up to a 0 we will begin by
making a few observations so how many
variables do we see here we see only one
variable X so we can say f of X is a
function in X we notice that X terms are
raised to unique powers so why do we use
the word unique this is because no two
terms of X at the same power yes we
notice that every X term is raised to a
unique power but what is the power of X
in the term a zero to answer this
question we need to understand that a
zero is nothing but a zero multiplied by
X raise to 0 so the power of the X term
is zero so we can say that the X terms
have non-negative integral powers so X
can be raised to positive integers or 0
also every term of X has a coefficient
the coefficients are a 0 a 1 a 2 and so
on up to a n these are all real
coefficients now in what order do we
write the terms should the terms be
written and increasing or decreasing
powers of X both the ways are
mathematically correct since they result
in the same function in our video we
have chosen to write the function in the
order of decreasing powers of X writing
the terms in descending order of power
is called the standard form now what's
the degree of a polynomial function can
we say that the degree of a function is
n this happens when the highest power of
X is N and the coefficient of x raise to
n a n is not equal to 0
what happens when a n is equal to zero
then the term a n multiplied by X raise
to n would be zero making the degree of
the polynomial n minus 1 so we know what
the degree of a polynomial is now we
look closely at the terms to understand
the anatomy of our polynomial function
here is our polynomial function of X a n
is the leading coefficient this is
because it's the coefficient of the X
term with the highest power n can you
guess what the terms a 0 a 1 times X and
times x squared are called they are
called the constant term the linear term
and the quadratic term respectively
this is because the power of X in each
of these terms is 0 1 & 2 respectively
now let's test our understanding to see
if the following functions are
polynomial functions or not if F in
brackets X equal to 5 a polynomial
function yes it's a polynomial function
of degree 0 this is because 5 can be
written as 5 x x raise to 0 here the
highest degree of the function is 0 what
about these two functions f of X equal
to 2 multiplied by X raise to 4 over 5
plus 2 and the function f of X is equal
to 6 over x squared
are they polynomial functions or not
they are both not polynomial functions
this is because the X term in f of X is
raised to a fractional power for it to
be a polynomial the power of X can only
be unknown negative integer similarly in
the second function the X term in press
of X is equal to a negative power hence
they both aren't polynomial functions
how about the function f of X is equal
to X raise to 4 plus X is this a
polynomial function we notice that the X
terms with powers 3/2 and 0 are missing
can we say that it's a polynomial
function of degree 4 absolutely a
polynomial function can have some X
terms missing so this discussion gave us
an overview about the
basic concepts of polynomial functions
in the next video we will learn about
rational functions
you